man monster myth Count Dracula is all of
these things and more but who is the man
behind the fangs in the last Voyage of
the Demeter there have been a lot of
live-action versions of Dracula over the
years but few of them are as outright
monstrous as a creature featured in
2023's the last Voyage of the Demeter
this version of the classic vampire is
an absolute horror to behold with
bat-like wings elongated ears and a
mouthful of razor sharp teeth
Satan's black blood pumping corruption
through his veins God's anger has come
upon this bezel like Jonah
it's such a ghoulish and human rendition
of the character in fact that it may be
easy for audiences to forget as an actor
under all that prosthetic makeup the
Dracula featured in the last Voyage of
the Demeter is played by none other than
Javier botet and the DraStic difference
in appearance between the real-life
actor and his on-screen Persona may
prove shocking to some viewers if
bowtet's name sounds familiar it's
probably because the performer has been
routinely involved in major horror films
for well over 15 years and in most cases
he's playing something spooky for the
bulk of his career in film and
television Javier botet has worked as a
specialized type of actor known as a
creature performer as the name implies
that means he more often than not
portrays inhuman or monstrous characters
that require a lot of preparation by way
of Prosthetics and makeup in addition to
Dracula botet has played some of the
most terrifying horror movie villains
out there he appeared as a crooked man
in The Conjuring 2 a xenomorph and alien
Covenant various forms of its in its and
its chapter 2 and Slenderman in
Slenderman to name it a few suffice to
say he knows his way around horror
interestingly enough boat set has a
unique capacity to physically manipulate
his body something which he uses to
great effect in his roles in an
interview the BBC he said I have a
disease called Marfan syndrome it makes
people skinnier taller and very flexible
so why was all my life very flexible all
my life doing weird tricks and things to
enjoy with my friends using very creepy
movement well many of boatset's biggest
roles are scare-filled creature flicks
he is also a mass credits and non-horor
Productions some of which have him in
Prosthetics While others don't recent
years have also seen him cross over to
mainstream sci-fi and fantasy franchises
appearing as an undead white in Game of
Thrones and one of the alien battle in
Star Trek Discovery while botet has
played a Cavalcade of Mainstay monsters
in his time he had longer waited the
opportunity to sink his teeth into the
role of Dracula the actor did once play
the character all the way back in a 2007
episode of the Spanish series Las
Hombres de Paco but he wanted nothing
more than to bring the horror icon to
life in a full-fledged monster movie
Last Voyage of the Demeter turned out to
be his big shot in an interview with
screen runs botet spoke about getting
casts as Dracula as well as reuniting
with director Andre overdale on last
Voyage of the Demeter he said for me it
would be an honor and finally it
happened it was great to know that Andre
overdale was directing because after a
lot of projects you need to meet a lot
of new people it's fine but always when
you are going to need a big crew when
you've worked already with somebody it's
easier it helps I remember it was so
easy and so nice Butte particularly
relished a chance to portray over Dahl's
unique take on Dracula a brutal
animalistic being who transforms from a
weakened wretch to a terrifyingly
powerful force of Darkness as he says
our Dracula was not a classical sexy guy
so for me it was good to try something
different something more heavy
thank you
[Music]